tomorrow right behind me they will Crown
King Charles III his coronation will
take place and the royal family is
getting ready but oh there's plenty of
drama coming in hot from California
Harry has touchdown now in the UK this
idea that there's going to be a cozy
tessette and family reunion where you
can forget that the brothers are not on
speaking terms my understanding is there
have been conversations between Charles
and Harry I'm told my source is very
close to the Prince of Wales that he
simply cannot forgive Harry for what
he's done Harry's expected to
immediately fly back to celebrate
Archie's fourth birthday Katie Nichol
author of the new Royals says it may
have been a smart move for Megan to have
stayed behind I think it was probably
the right decision because I think had
she come they may have been booed in the
streets and that would have been
terrible what would Diana have thought
of the way things are between Charles
and Harry now I think she would have
been unhappy with and she would have
tried to fix and I'm quite sure she
could have fixed this one Princess
Diana's former private secretary Patrick
who was portrayed in the crown told me
Megan not being here is a missed
opportunity the country has lost a lot
through losing Harry and Megan but they
have lost a lot too the things they
could have accomplished as fully paid up
members of the royal family around the
world there's no limit to it will they
ever patch things up the winds is a
famous for bearing a grudge over a long
time I mean at the end it's a family
it's not good for families to be to be
ruptured in this way but there's an
awful lot of compromise to be done but
does the British public hold a grudge
with Camilla author Andrew Morton and
Patrick say yes she was one of the most
reviled women in Britain because she was
deemed to have broken up the marriage of
Charles and Diana
she's not Queen in the sense that Queen
Elizabeth was Queen she's Queen consort
even though the king wants us to call
her the queen but the final rehearsal in
prince Andrew was missing I would be
surprised if he wasn't at the coronation
I don't think we're going to see him up
on the balcony I don't think you're
going to see him have a prominent role
in the same way that the Duke of Sussex
won't either I mean I think the palace
have found a clever way to sidestep the
issue of the of the problematic members
of the Royal Family by really putting
the spotlight on the king queen and the
Wales is and then the working members of
the royal family you know there is this
expectation that a lot of people working
to show up for the coronation but the
night before and look at how deep the
crowds and the tents are and remember
this rain is expected
today King Charles William and Kate
surprised well-wishers after a luncheon
and we couldn't help but notice Kate may
have given a subtle nod to Megan wearing
the same 600 black heels that are a
favorite of the duchess
no doubt all eyes will be on the Royal
fashion and all the kids but let's break
down the big event by the Numbers
approximately 300 million are expected
to watch on TV 2200 people will be in
attendance for the two-hour ceremony the
bill expected to be 126 million dollars
all paid by taxpayers but the palace
does contribute an undisclosed amount
too
UK pubs expect to pour 62 million pints
that's about 151 million dollars in beer
sales I was uh thrilled and honored and
but completely terrified composer
Patrick Doyle who's done movies like
Harry Potter and brave wrote the
coronation March in just two months for
the 40-piece symphony orchestra he said
it could be less than four minutes but
not one second over so the piece comes
in three minutes 55 seconds with
reverberation today I was with Roderick
Williams who also composed music and
will be singing during the ceremony what
was the call like when they tell you
they want you to be a part of the
coronation what they asked me was very
specific the King's favorite hymn tune
is slain be thou my vision so he'd asked
for something that was kind of like a a
fantasy variation on that what will this
moment mean for you knowing that people
around the world are watching but also
to be a man of color being a part of the
coronation when you look at the
coronations going back through history
um it's of course it is a single color
yes I think it's wonderful that it's so
important to the king to be able to
represent
All Nations I hope I have the focus to
stay in the present and enjoy it in real
time
no that's not Prince Harry and Meghan
Markle out and about in the UK it
collects who were discovered governed by
curator Allison Jackson it's taken me
two years to find a mega so I've seen
200 Megan's and none of them look like
Mega Allison has many Royal lookalikes
on her roster check out this
over-the-top cat fight between Megan and
Kate Middleton these shots of Prince
William reading then tearing up his
brother's book and a full-on Royal Brawl
but the h m doppelgangers in London for
coronation weekend are getting nothing
but love this has been quite nice I got
a lot of smile
a smile
surprisingly everybody seems to be quite
supportive here in the UK I found it's
taken us about half an hour just to move
100 yards because everybody has wanted a
selfie
[Music]